Speaker 2: One more kind of Tulsi related thing.
Congresswoman Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez held a town
hall recently and it got invaded by you know I
don't want to you I know some people call them
the Tulsi Stans. Some call them the tool cells.
I don't know who they are. There are people who
just seem obsessed with Tulsi Gabbard. And they
exploded during. In AOC Town Hall. Take a look
at this, Congresswoman. None of.
Speaker 1: This matters unless
there's a nuclear war, which
you voted to send arms.
Unidentified: And weapons to Ukraine.
This is what the Democratic Party.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Unidentified: You
originally voted. You ran as an outsider.
Yet you've been voting to start this war.
Speaker 1: Good morning.
Speaker 2: She voted to start a war in Ukraine.
I mean, what are you talking about, going.
Unidentified: To war with Russia? The librarian
put it this way There will be no neighbors.
Speaker 1: If there is a nuclear bomb.
Speaker 2: So now a second guy pops up.
Speaker 5: You wanted to mobilize
and send money for Ukrainian Nazis.
Speaker 2: Now the entire Ukrainian Nazis thing.
Are there some Nazis in Ukraine? Yes, there
are Nazis in the U.S. as well. There's a lot
of now that the US military has quite
a problem with right wing extremism.
But saying that what we're
doing is supporting Nazis by
slightly helping Ukraine to defend itself against
this invasion of aggression from Russia. You're
really missing the boat.
Speaker 4: You're a.
Speaker 5: Coward. You're a progressive socialist.
Well, are you against the war mobilization?
He's telling the right truth. You have
done nothing toxic ever has shown guts.
Speaker 2: It's almost like they're paid people.
But I'm not. I'm not saying they are, but it's
so outrageous, you would say. Nobody could
really believe this. You must be getting paid.
Speaker 5: You show them how it is. I believed in
you. And you became the very thing you fought to
fight against. That's what you become.
Speaker 2:
Listen, there are many fair criticisms of
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez. But you're a warmonger.
I don't know that that's really the
right critique for AOC. And again,
when when you only have a hammer, everything looks
like a nail when you're obsessed with the cult of
personality around Tulsi Gabbard. Anybody with a
different view is wrong. And if it's a warmonger
or whatever it is, you assign them that label. And
that's what we're seeing here. And it's quite sad.